dass es jetzt so netz bekommen zu einer
neuen folge road to top ten in den
tiroler one was man denkt und wir
checken kurz unser elo unser aktueller
stand ist wie zum ende der letzten folge
1300 und wir brauchen mindestens 1144
top ten zu kommen
ich würde sagen wir legen jetzt einfach
mal straight los sehen zu dass wir unser
100 euro bekommen und am ende des über
die outtakes viel spaß übrigens leute
für alle die das format noch nicht gerne
geht darum in die top ten der renk
bewertung aufgenommen zu kommen und ich
hab meine kopfhörer nicht eingesteckt
ach du scheiße ok egal
wir machen das jetzt alles über boxen
okay es ist einfach geil
wir haben es aber den ingame sound über
lautsprecher ist stark was macht er da
bist im boden
was kann
fertig ist der mensch aller zeiten ein
ich will keine kopfhörer
sorry ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll
fleischhacker schreibt fall schaden
bekommen ja dann dann greife nicht ein
wenig falschen bekommen soll
ok also apple kämpfen gut ich denke fall
schaden aber dann bin ich nicht will
dann wirklich ok 20 euro im stage und
ich habe das mal so war der kopf phasen
drin und jetzt mal richtig anders
bereits jetzt kann es rund gm gegenüber
rsa key first und second auch dann
erwischt uns nicht so richtig damals so
übertrieben ist ein game
der war echt gut aus der war nicht
schlecht aus und sagen ja massa macht so
gut da dass sich das nicht rächt der war
gut im fallen aus das sieht man selten
dass einer so gut hier irgendwie fallen
ausreichen kann
das lasse ich bin lasse ich kenne das
ich kenne
lass dich kehlen da braucht nicht mehr
viel nein ich werde der fall dem getötet
nein nicht weglaufen nahe an der angel
hat wieder los die alleinigen gott leute
tut mir das nicht ein alter egal ich
will jetzt die top 3 meerwasser junge
dieser trotzdem heiter
egal wir wollen jetzt den ebenso gegeben
am anfang konnte ich bin ja noch was er
davon hält weiß auch nicht wenig
zwei herzen
das ist mir ganz schön unter druck die
gute aber komm wir holen uns denen wir
holen uns den wir uns denn alles klar
321 leute ich bin heute übrigens extra
früh aufgestanden um das video noch
aufzunehmen
für mich geht es gleich weiter in die
uni block i p frankfurt ja ok fanny
fanny fanny wie das aufregt junger
mensch machen kommission als auch was
wir können sie für leben haben
nein ich weiß dass das nicht aufgeregt
hat aber komm mal runter
okay es geht weiter es ist eine einnahme
das ist schlecht das ist ganz ganz
schlecht wird kann ich schon mal gar
nicht ab
der fall geht ins leere
jan eichhorn halte ich wenn die falle
hineingetappt die ermittler gestellt hat
indem man wegläuft und mich damit den
bogen erwischt war richtig knapp ein
halbes herz oder so egal ob den geholt
so jetzt werde jetzt auf wen erwartet da
erwartet da locker mit gärten bogen oder
doch nicht
nämlich die deutsche ok erwartet er
damit mit gameplay bogen läuft rückwärts
sehe ich noch mal klinik hotspur
okay was ist mit dem lustig den an
was war das denn
wer die typischen wasser müssen wasser
und noch einfallen bist du weg zu gott
jetzt bitte nicht nicht so eine rolle
bitte keine rolle dass ich gehe jetzt
mal ja kommen
man kann so hart um diesen baum umgangen
wie hat der stresspegel egal wer kriegt
nur zwei spitzen
er hat nicht mehr viele leben der junge
nicht mehr viele leben hatte ich finde
er hat nicht wie viele lieber nicht
gesagt hat er macht mich wieder für die
machen wir alle fertig hier schon
erstaunt weil das ging an die substanz
alter schwede das war echt ein harter
kampf gesehen hat muss man kurz den
laser saubermachen steht das jetzt
gesehen erst so richtig austoben
weggerissen kann ich nichts machen
komm wieder vorkommt und ab ins gesicht
er schwebte auch richtig so ein blog
über dem boden
ein junger richtige action ich will die
20 jedoch nicht schon wieder von ihren
ich muss mir die holen
gebt mir die decke geht mir dein ego die
mir alles was du hast echt aus alter
noch ein beau noch zwei hits erwischt
alter schwede war das knapp
der 1400 gfl älter als der nächste
können dass die 1360 euro für uns sein
dieser gegner ist hopp ist weiß liegt da
wahrscheinlich gebogen natürlich kommt
der frist 234 pfeile von uns opfert die
sind alle so roddick comics roddick
okay geht der komplette man ja sehr
schön 10 herzen
86 prozent trefferquote das ist nicht
schlecht
das könnte die 1360 sein wenn wir uns
jetzt gut anstellen
komm mach es kein doppel markus babbel
machen uns keine schraube mal lieber
weil die sache gut und ich konnte nicht
kommen sehen und es dauert sehr schön
pandeya check gb gute gewissen ein
gewisser schiffe gebiss merken ganz
wichtig bis dahin will
so sei schon okay mir mal gesagt was ich
mehr so denker 1360 wir brauchen noch
zwei games in folge
so liebe leid denn es ist die nächste
runde
der gegner heißt aber auch wirklich
gewonnen ist oder ob er nur läuft
kommentiert das ok nice ja die schwert
jetzt treffen ihn ganz gut es geht
wieder die verstecke reihe hinten los
sollten wir sollten aber es ist halt
immer so das risiko
man könnte auf ihn drauf gehen weiß aber
nicht ob man ihn dann erwischt wenn es
soweit ist
aber in dem fall hat mir glück und die
1400 elo das gesetzte ziel rückt näher
wir brauchen jetzt auch hier ein kind
kommt zack zack zack zack zack frist
setzen was halbes herz aufwärts geholt
er hat das geholt hat ist cool da das
gros des gut aufpassen lassen dürfen
auch nicht zu entspannter angehen
er trifft nämlich auch ganz gute bogen
trifft es ziemlich gut den bogen
apa red der gut gefressen bogen etwas
was dir alter ja diese art von dem man
richtig gut richtig gut da konnte ich
überhaupt nicht erwischt es geschafft
und jetzt der letzte kampf ist noch mal
der gleiche gegner
es ist noch mal der gleiche gegner hat
er sich jetzt eingestellt auf und können
wir noch mal besiegen
letztmals war in der letzten runde schon
richtig knapp reicht es jetzt nochmal
oder guten zweck er ist auf jeden fall
wieder am angeln oder geht wieder hinten
hin und versteckt sich dann ist es
einfach das ist ich weiß da ist es nur
gute taktik glaube ich wenn man
tatsächlich die gegner tatsächlich ich
bin so aufgeregt tatsächlich die gegner
ein bisschen kommen lassen kann wenn man
sich da hinten nach rom oder wenn man
sich hier verstecken damit den bogen
kann
es ist keine schlechte taktik ist
natürlich doof wenn man dann sozusagen
gezwungen ist den angreifer zu machen
und draufzugehen
denn dann hat man ein problem weil wie
gesagt okay forstwirt mich betrifft gut
er trifft die richtig gut trifft die
fahrer richtig gut und ich nutze mal die
gelegenheit um einfach ein bisschen hier
hinten raus r2 folgetag sports bekommen
jetzt mit dem nahkampf kommen wir ohne
das weiß der vater nein
wie knapp alte schwede soli bedeutet das
war's schon für heute es lief richtig
gut wissen auf 1400 werden wieder
hundert kilowatt sowie in jeder folge
lasse gerne daumen nach oben da bevor
wir jetzt gleich noch weiter zu den
outtakes gehen die fallen heute ein
bisschen kürzer aus weil es eigentlich
ganz gut lief wir sind zum nächsten
video wieder haut rein macht's gut und
viel spaß mit dem text cab
kommission als ob was wir nicht
gebrauchen das schlechte oder nerven
danke ich das hasse
o